madame pour jouer aux billes et ce qu'il
faut suivre un entraînement intensif à
sa main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et si vous savez mon fils mais non je
n'ai pas de vie pour toi monsieur mais
pas emballé plus mais c'est à cette date
que d'hier bon parce que c'est toujours
top 10 et c'est tout et sportives
[Applaudissements]
messieurs vous savez au pied s'il vous
plaît vous savez tpir
oui monsieur pascal à la pasta
saint-andré des poussières d'habitude
dans le choix obéit à tout le monde ici
joue au pire je pas du tout
monsieur le maire que pensez vous de cet
engouement pour les billes dans votre
commune craignez vous pas un peu que vos
administrés soient pris pour des billes
alors monsieur le président on se trouve
sur le billot drôme international de
saint andré de cruzières omc est ce que
vous pourriez nous rappeler le règlement
aux lettres et cm2 m'essayer en triangle
vous voyez il faut pour l'équipe on
s'approchait du triangle et l'api est la
plus près et toi tu irais pour sortir le
pire et chaque enfant itanium points et
gestion de gagner parce que je vous malo
six mois les son vieux père
et à
[Musique]
c'est à vous riez pas c'est assez de
l'arrêt je suis perdu allez si ça y est
alors c'est ça qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
monsieur le curé entre vous et les cieux
le maire quel est celui des deux qui
touchent le plus sa vie sa première fois
que je joue ensemble et brice la
première fois alors
et de rappeler sous louer vous arrive
souvent devancé vauvy jamais c'était la
première fois que vous ramassez moby
blanc et agréé par vous et moi là oui il
ya bien longtemps mais j'ai été
d'ailleurs sorti chez moi pour pour les
billes et physiquement en dessous de la
souplesse dans les jambes point que tout
cela c'est pas si bien que c'est quand
même un élément comme peut-être un ponte
mal à monteils ça c'est chapeau
on dit que dans votre paroisse labit a
remplacé le ch'ti c'est vrai oh je crois
qu'ils font bon ménage
ou alors vous pointez s il me semble que
vous ne réussissez pas ce qui vous
arrive de prendre le problème bille en
tête
nous sommes pas des pires vous soumettez
pillon me battais bill c'est difficile
très difficile comme ça faut pas avoir
de dix mois dans les doigts il faut que
les articulations cinq jours patrice
cartier photos étaient repartis du
chapelain vous voyez mais faut pas tasca
rapide même pas tu crevier on ne peut
pas tout et n'importe où
voilà l'affairé dans le sac de billes
les 15 166 licenciés de l'association
nationale des joueurs de baseball
désormais vidé leur sac gris avec leurs
homologues anglais devenir de véritables
roule ta bille j'ai gagné sur maya côté
moustiques on peut aussi est monsieur
[Musique]
ah oui